well so lorraine a lot of people are
more and more people
seem to be cooking at home during the
pandemic have
have you noticed that uh definitely uh
we hear it all the time from listeners
to our two sharp chefs in a microphone
podcast
um they're always writing in calling in
and on our social media telling us
that they're always looking for new
recipes because a lot of people even
though we have you know
restaurants kind of open right now and
we have to go
um they might sometimes feel safer or
honestly just they feel like it's easier
because they can find things in their
pantry
so what we've been trying to do is talk
about things that a lot of people just
have right there
in their kitchen in their pantry rather
than trying to come up with all these
exotic ingredients
and you were telling me before we
started here that you have something
really
simple and pretty darn quick for for us
to share today what what are we going to
do
yes we're going to do comfort cake in a
cup
and it's super simple um you just need
some sort of mug
i like a wide brim one so i can see my
cake and i have more space to eat
um a little bit of cooking spray spray
it
let it sit on the side for a bit super
fast
1 4 cup of cake flour
two tablespoons of cocoa powder
two to three tablespoons of sugar um i
use monk fruit sweetener because i'm
borderline diabetic
um it's interchangeable one to one with
sugar but feel free to use stevia if you
like
a little bit less stevia because it's a
little bit sweeter taste
use regular sugar use a mixture of brown
sugar white sugar all of it works
um 1 4 teaspoon of baking powder
that is not interchangeable with baking
soda no
1 4 cup of milk um it works best with a
nice whole milk
uh cow's milk but i am trying to do a
little less dairy
so i'm doing almond milk which totally
works oat milk works soy milk any of it
um 1 4 teaspoon of vanilla extract
um i use pure and then two tablespoons
of
vegetable oil canola oil olive oil works
but it tends to be a little olive oil
strong so it kind of depends on your
taste there
um and then we're just gonna mix it up
with that's pretty
amazing and these are common ingredients
that folks
probably have already in their pantry
yes and the cocoa powder i mean feel
free to use
any unsweetened cocoa powder so you can
even use like your dark chocolate hot
chocolate powder if you like
um mix it up i like to give it a good
mix
most people have a whisk i would think
whisk is a fairly common instrument
i like it because it's mine um obviously
wouldn't do that if i was serving other
people
right i use a spatula because i never
like to waste anything
sure um you can certainly use a spoon
and just pour it in
but a spatula gets it so that you're not
wasting anything
um because so this is waste
batter for one cake yes
yes and feel free to lick the bowl as
well
and the spatula it's actually good to do
that because you can kind of feel where
your taste buds are
um people like different amounts of
sugar when i say two to three
tablespoons
i'm more of a two tablespoons and one
teaspoon person
but some people like more sugar that's
why i say up to three tablespoons it's
not gonna ruin the cake in any kind of
way
then the special part at the end here
it's gonna make it nice and moist and
chocolatey in the middle
i use dark chocolate chips about one
tablespoon
um that's totally a crab shoot do
whatever you want one tablespoon tape
two tablespoons whatever you like
microwave
super easy pop it in
i go one minute and 15 seconds
now we all have different microwave
powers you know like different wattage
right um so you might have to play with
it a little bit
um so on the recipe i say one minute to
130.
so depending on the wattage of the
microwave um
and like the wideness the thinness of
your mug
whether it's glass or ceramic it's a
little bit different so somewhere in
there
i do 150. um yeah 115 it comes out
i would give it a couple of seconds to
rest and then there's a fun part at the
end here
um when you take it out yeah
you can do whatever you want to
customize it you can keep it just
chocolate chip
it's beautiful it tastes very good um
you can go sprinkles
you could go red hots mint and chips
maybe some heath bar um pretzels i like
pretzels i like the salty sweet kind of
combination
um feel free to do like a salted caramel
sauce that would be super delicious
uh or if you're feeling uh more than
mostly funny nate
go nuts and do all of it all in
make it like a dumpster chocolate cake
and then whipped cream
um whipped cream um a nice scoop of ice
cream
would be wonderful um there's a bunch of
different ways to customize it customize
this personalize it
make it your own i like this recipe
because
if i'm at home alone or i'm the only one
that wants dessert i can have it
um a lot of people in the pandemic right
now are stuck at home alone
um so they don't have to make a big cake
and
they can just have like a sweet treat
nice comforting
warm uh waste
look at that and so you know you if if
you
feel like if you know you try that for
yourself and you go yeah maybe not
you have the thrill and the joy of
eating it all yourself and saying i want
to do this differently next time
yeah and then if you have two people or
if you have two people and some kids
um it's 65 seconds a minute and a half
for each one so how much how long is
that going to take you five minutes to
do the whole family
um so this is me i'm a sprinkles girl
um it's super moist the center is gonna
be kind of molten
because of the chocolate chips that you
put there um
why it kind of sucks into the center um
another way to personalize this instead
of doing the chocolate chips you can do
a hazelnut spread i love that the
nutella
yes exactly or if you want to do some
sort of peanut butter cashew butter
almond butter
um but you can see like how moist it is
in the center
yeah it's kind of like a lava cake and
then the sides
are just really cakey um i use a cake
flour because i find that you know it's
got a better texture
it's more fluffy cake flour is um
fine flour um but certainly
um use all-purpose flour because a lot
of people might have that instead of
cake powder in their cupboard
um i'm crazy i've got like 10 different
flowers in there
i'm a little nutty uh culinary nerd so
i've got all kinds of things happening
but you know ap
not associated press all-purpose flour
um
totally works yeah it's delicious um
it's just like
give it a shot there lorraine
super chocolaty um it's very very warm
so be careful about that
yeah uh yeah so it's delicious super
easy
couple minutes and you're done so add
chocolate face
absolutely so before we run on because
this has just been perfect
but just the idea of folks taking more
control of what they're putting in their
bodies doing
cooking for themselves people are i
think
i don't know if enlightened is the right
word but people are seeing the value
and stuff that some kids just grow up
thinking that food just shows up in a
shelf in a store somewhere
not realizing that this is stuff that we
make
yes and you know i highly recommend
that you know if you do have children uh
do this with them
you saw how simple it was it's so easy
for them to measure things out with you
um i had it knees and plaster already
for you
but that's a fun thing to do with your
children so just you know hey let me
show you what a tablespoon looks like
this is what a quarter cup looks like
you know you need to flatten it out
um that kind of stuff is great to do
with them um
it gives them ownership of what they're
eating um i
honestly would recommend that with
especially with vegetables to do that
with your children
because when they're growing their
vegetables cutting their vegetables
making vegetables with you in the
kitchen they're more likely to eat them
so that's the other thing it's like
you're you're you're teaching them these
great
healthy um habits that they can take
with them when they leave you
we might even be slipping a little bit
of math in him on there with his half a
cup half a teaspoon
right right exactly
exactly teach them conversions
well yeah we don't want to go that far
well lorraine i can't thank you enough
for spending a few minutes with us and
showing us this simple recipe
and um enabling also seems like too
fancy of a word but you know
letting folks know that you've got this
you can go ahead and have fun in the
kitchen
it's so easy and the reason why i like
to show you all these personalized ways
of doing it
is because although you don't want to go
crazy with baking soda or baking powder
you know the things that are going to be
like a leavener and it's going to affect
your baking
you can have fun with the other stuff
the stuff that you add
and when you do that you're happy you're
it's a joyful place to be in the kitchen
because a lot of us are now forced to be
in the kitchen
why not smile why not put on some music
have fun and be like i'm gonna try
something new today i'm gonna try red
hots in my chocolate cake
i'm gonna try whatever you know this is
something that could be fun for the
family but it's also just
a nice relaxing time for me it is to
just kind of
you know things are going on outside of
us um
not everything is great that's happening
outside of us this is something that you
can control
yeah in your own home and have a room
before we run i also want to
boast a little bit of i learned a word
for myself when i learned
how to make mayonnaise yes
learned the word emulsify
almo you're a scientist you're a
meteorologist
aren't you emulsify that's an easy one
but it's amazing to see what happens
just by whipping up an egg yolk and a
couple of eggs and some mustard
and juice citrus juice and you you drip
in the oil very slowly and it
the the process of science makes it into
something saucy
it's science and creativity that's
cooking science plus creativity equals
amazing cooking
and that science that you use with
emulsifying also works perfectly with
dressings
so now you can make all your own
dressings nate
i'll give it a shot lorraine thank you
so much